willkommen zurück zu „Quanteninformation und -berechnung verstehen" – mein Name ist John Watrous und ich bin technischer Direktor für Bildung bei IBM
Quantum. Dies ist Lektion 15 der Serie und die dritte Lektion der vierten Einheit, die sich mit Quantenfehler-
korrektur befasst. Bisher haben wir einige Beispiele für Quantenfehlerkorrektur-Codes gesehen, darunter den Neun-qubit-Shore-
Code, den Sieben-qubit-Steane-Code und den Fünf-qubit-Code, und wir haben auch den Stabilisatorformalismus besprochen, der
uns ein mathematisches Fundament liefert, von dem aus wir diese und viele andere Quantenfehlerkorrektur-
Codes beschreiben und analysieren können. Die Codes, die ich gerade erwähnt habe, sind zweifellos interessant und stellen einen natürlichen Ausgangspunkt für eine
Erkundung der Quantenfehlerkorrektur dar. Das Problem ist, dass sie nur eine sehr niedrige Fehlerrate tolerieren können.
Einen Fehler auf einem von fünf, sieben oder neun qubits zu korrigieren ist nicht schlecht, aber aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach – zumindest soweit wir vermuten –
werden wir in der Lage sein müssen, weitaus mehr Fehler zu tolerieren, um groß angelegtes Quantencomputing zur
Realität zu machen. In dieser Lektion werfen wir einen ersten Blick auf einige ausgefeiltere Konstruktionen von Quantenfehlerkorrektur-Codes, einschließlich Codes, die
eine viel höhere Fehlerrate tolerieren können als die bisher gesehenen, und die als vielversprechende Kandidaten für praktische Quantenfehlerkorrektur in
tatsächlichen physischen Geräten angesehen werden. Hier ist ein kurzer Überblick über die Lektion: Wir beginnen mit einer Klasse von
Quantenfehlerkorrektur-Codes, die als CSS-Codes bekannt sind – benannt nach den Forschern, die sie erstmals entdeckt haben: Robert Calderbank, Peter
Shor und Andrew Steane. Die CSS-Code-Konstruktion erlaubt es, bestimmte Paare klassischer
Fehlerkorrektur-Codes zu nehmen und sie zu einem Quantenfehlerkorrektur-Code zu kombinieren. Als Teil dieser Diskussion werden wir
einen recht schnellen Blick auf klassische lineare Codes werfen und wir werden auch einige der grundlegenden Eigenschaften von CSS-
Codes besprechen. Der zweite Teil der Lektion behandelt einen Code, der als Toric Code bekannt ist – ein fundamentales und wirklich
schönes Beispiel für einen Quantenfehlerkorrektur-Code, der eine relativ hohe Fehlerrate tolerieren kann. Tatsächlich ist der
Toric Code kein einzelnes Beispiel für einen Quantenfehlerkorrektur-Code, sondern eine unendliche Familie von Codes – einer für jede
positive ganze Zahl ab Zwei. Und im letzten Teil der Lektion werden wir kurz ein paar andere
Familien von Quanten-Codes besprechen, darunter Surface Codes, die eng mit dem Toric Code verwandt sind, sowie
Color Codes. Man hat klassische Fehlerkorrektur-Codes seit den 1940er Jahren erforscht –
ein faszinierendes und reichhaltiges Gebiet. Lineare Codes sind vielleicht der einfachste Typ klassischer Fehler-
korrektur-Codes. Ich werde gleich genau erklären, was das Wort „linear" in diesem Zusammenhang bedeutet, aber ein einfacher
Weg, sie zu beschreiben, ist: Sie sind Stabilisator-Codes, die zufällig klassisch sind. Und wir werden bald sehen, dass
CSS-Codes im Wesentlichen Paare klassischer linearer Codes sind, die zusammengeführt werden, um einen Quantenfehler-
korrektur-Code zu erzeugen. Daher werden wir für diese Diskussion einige grundlegende Dinge über
klassische lineare Codes verstehen müssen. Zunächst nehmen wir Sigma als das binäre Alphabet für diese gesamte
Diskussion. Wenn wir nun von einem klassischen linearen Code sprechen, meinen wir eine Menge C binärer Zeichenketten der Länge n für eine
positive ganze Zahl n, die genau eine grundlegende Eigenschaft erfüllt: Wenn u und v binäre Zeichenketten in C sind, dann ist die Zeichenkette
u XOR v ebenfalls in C. Dabei bedeutet u XOR v das bitweise exklusive Oder von u und v – genauso
wie wir es mehrfach in Lektion fünf und sechs im Abschnitt über Quantenalgorithmen der Serie gesehen haben. Und das ist es, was es bedeutet, dass ein
klassischer Code linear ist. Im Wesentlichen betrachten wir binäre Zeichenketten der Länge n als n-dimensionale Vektoren,
bei denen die Einträge alle entweder null oder eins sind, aber anstelle der gewöhnlichen Vektoraddition über den reellen oder komplexen
Zahlen verwenden wir Addition modulo 2, was einfach das XOR ist. Wenn wir also
zwei Codewörter u und v haben – das heißt, u und v sind binäre Zeichenketten in C –, dann muss u plus v modulo 2, oder mit anderen Worten u XOR
v, ebenfalls ein Codewort in C sein. Und diese Implikation muss übrigens auch dann gelten, wenn u gleich v ist – nichts schließt
diese Möglichkeit aus. Und das impliziert, dass jeder klassische lineare Code die Null-Zeichenkette enthalten muss, weil das
bitweise XOR einer beliebigen Zeichenkette mit sich selbst die Null-Zeichenkette ergibt. Zum Beispiel ist der Drei-Bit-
Wiederholungscode ein klassischer linearer Code. Insbesondere gibt es zwei mögliche Wahlen für u und zwei mögliche
Wahlen für v, und es ist eine recht triviale Angelegenheit, alle möglichen Paare durchzugehen und zu sehen, dass wir immer ein Codewort erhalten, wenn wir das bitweise
XOR berechnen. Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel, das als 7-4-3-Hamming-Code bezeichnet wird. Dies ist einer der allerersten klassischen Fehler-
korrektur-Codes, der je entdeckt wurde. Er besteht aus 16 binären Zeichenketten der Länge sieben. Es gibt eine sehr einfache Logik
hinter der Auswahl dieser Zeichenketten, aber das werde ich in diesem Video nicht erklären. Außerdem sollte ich erwähnen, dass du diese Zeichenketten manchmal umgekehrt siehst,
aber der Hauptpunkt ist jetzt: Wenn wir zwei dieser Zeichenketten nehmen und sie XOR-verknüpfen, erhalten wir eine weitere Zeichenkette im
Code. Es ist also ein linearer Code, und die Schreibweise 7-4-3 in einfachen eckigen Klammern bedeutet etwas analoges zur doppelten
eckigen Klammernotation, die ich in der vorherigen Lektion für Stabilisator-Codes erwähnt habe – nur dass sie hier für klassische lineare
Codes gilt. Insbesondere haben Codewörter sieben Bits, es gibt 16 Codewörter, wir können also vier Bits mit dem Code kodieren, und
er ist zufällig ein Distanz-3-Code, was bedeutet, dass du mindestens drei Bits eines Codeworts umkehren musst, um ein
anderes Codewort zu erhalten. Das impliziert, dass er bis zu einem Bit-Flip-Fehler korrigieren kann. Das sind einfache Beispiele für
Codes, aber selbst das Beispiel des 7-4-3-Hamming-Codes wirkt irgendwie rätselhaft, wenn wir einfach alle Codewörter auflisten. Wir brauchen also bessere Möglichkeiten,
klassische lineare Codes zu beschreiben. Und es gibt zwei natürliche Wege, das zu tun. Eine Möglichkeit ist, klassische
lineare Codes durch eine minimale Menge von Codewörtern zu beschreiben, die den Code erzeugen – das heißt, indem wir alle möglichen
Teilmengen dieser Codewörter nehmen und sie XOR-verknüpfen, erhalten wir den gesamten Code. Das wird in mathematischen Begriffen
hier auf dem Bildschirm ausgedrückt. Eine weitere Sichtweise ist, dass wir diesen Code als Unterraum eines Vektorraums betrachten, und diese Menge
von Erzeugern ist eine Basis für diesen Unterraum – mit dem Hinweis, dass dies ein Vektorraum ist, in dem Arithmetik modulo 2 durchgeführt wird. Wenn wir m Erzeuger haben,
erhalten wir am Ende einen Code mit 2 hoch m Elementen. Jeder Erzeuger verdoppelt die Anzahl der Elemente im Code, und
das stimmt damit überein, dass klassische lineare Codes über dem binären Alphabet immer eine Anzahl von Zeichenketten enthalten, die eine Potenz von
zwei ist. Der zweite natürliche Weg, einen klassischen linearen Code zu beschreiben, sind Paritätsprüfungen. Konkret ist das eine minimale
Liste binärer Zeichenketten mit derselben Länge wie die Zeichenketten im Code, sodass die Zeichenketten im Code genau diejenigen sind, deren binäres
Skalarprodukt mit jeder dieser Paritätsprüfungs-Zeichenketten null ist, wobei das binäre Skalarprodukt einfach das gewöhnliche
innere Produkt modulo 2 ist. Und das ist wieder etwas, das wir in Lektion fünf im Kontext von Quanten-
Algorithmen kennengelernt haben. Der Grund, warum sie Paritätsprüfungs-Zeichenketten genannt werden, ist, dass eine gegebene Zeichenkette u das binäre Produkt gleich
null mit v hat genau dann, wenn die Bits von u, die den Einsen in v entsprechen, geradzahlige
Parität haben. Wenn wir einen klassischen linearen Code auf diese Weise beschreiben – durch eine minimale Liste von Paritätsprüfungs-Zeichenketten –, dann ist jede Paritäts-
Die Check-Zeichenkette teilt die Anzahl der Zeichenketten im Code durch zwei, sodass wir für einen einzelnen Code, der auf diese zwei verschiedenen Arten beschrieben wird, immer m + r·al haben werden.
Ein wichtiger Hinweis: Das binäre Skalarprodukt ist kein inneres Produkt im formalen Sinne, und
insbesondere bedeutet es nicht, dass zwei Zeichenketten mit binärem Skalarprodukt gleich null orthogonal sind, in der Art, wie wir normalerweise über
Orthogonalität nachdenken. Zum Beispiel ist das binäre Skalarprodukt der Zeichenkette 1 1 mit sich selbst null – es ist also möglich, dass
eine dieser Paritätsprüf-Zeichenketten selbst im Code enthalten ist. Das ist einfach etwas, das man im
Hinterkopf behalten sollte. Zum Beispiel wissen wir bereits, dass der 3-Bit-Repetitionscode ein linearer Code ist, sodass er auf beiden dieser
Arten beschrieben werden kann. Insbesondere gibt es nur eine Wahl für einen Generator, der funktioniert, und das ist 1 1 1. Alternativ können wir ihn beschreiben
mit diesen zwei Paritätsprüf-Zeichenketten, die aus unseren früheren Diskussionen über diesen Code bekannt sein sollten.
Für den 7-4-3-Hamming-Code können wir diese Generatoren und diese Paritätsprüfungen verwenden
und hier sind übrigens alle unsere Paritätsprüf-Zeichenketten selbst im Code enthalten.
Ein letzter Kommentar zu klassischen linearen Codes, um sie mit dem Stabilisatorformalismus zu verbinden: Diese Paritätsprüfungen
sind äquivalent zu Stabilisatorgeneratoren, in denen nur Z- und Identitäts-Pauli-Matrizen vorkommen. Zum Beispiel entsprechen die Paritätsprüfungen
1 1 0 und 0 1 1 für den 3-Bit-Repetitionscode genau den Stabilisatorgeneratoren Z Z Identität
und Identität Z Z. Das ist konsistent mit unserer Diskussion über Observablen dieser Art aus der vorherigen
Lektion. Als nächstes werden wir CSS-Codes besprechen, das sind Stabilisatorcodes, die man durch Kombination bestimmter
Paare klassischer linearer Codes erhalten kann, die die gleiche Anzahl an Bits in ihren Kodierungen haben. Das funktioniert nicht für beliebige zwei
klassische lineare Codes – die beiden Codes müssen eine bestimmte Beziehung zueinander haben, wie wir bald sehen werden. Dennoch
eröffnet diese Konstruktion viele Möglichkeiten für Quantenfehlerkorrektur-Codes, die teilweise auf Erkenntnissen aus über 75 Jahren
klassischer Codierungstheorie basieren. Ich habe bereits erwähnt, dass im Stabilisatorformalismus Stabilisatoren,
die nur Z- und Identitäts-Pauli-Matrizen enthalten, äquivalent zu Paritätsprüfungen sind. Zum Beispiel im 3-Bit-
Repetitionscode können wir die Paritätsprüf-Zeichenketten 1 1 0 und 0 1 1 verwenden, die erzwingen, dass die beiden linken Bits
gleich sind und die beiden rechten Bits gleich sind – für jede Zeichenkette im Code. Diese zwei Paritätsprüf-Zeichenketten entsprechen genau den Stabilisatoren
Z Z Identität und Identität Z Z. Für den 7-4-3-Hamming-Code können wir
diese Paritätsprüf-Zeichenketten verwenden. Sie entsprechen diesen Stabilisatorgeneratoren, wobei wir jede Eins einfach durch ein Z und jede Null durch die Identität ersetzen.
Du erkennst diese Stabilisatorgeneratoren vielleicht, denn es sind drei der sechs Stabilisatorgeneratoren des 7-qubit Steane-Codes. Das ist
sicher kein Zufall, und wir werden bald genau sehen, was hier passiert. Wir werden Stabilisatorgeneratoren dieser Art als Z-
Stabilisatorgeneratoren bezeichnen, also solche, die nur Pauli-Z und Identitäts-Tensorfaktoren enthalten.
X und Y kommen also in einem Z-Stabilisatorgenerator nie vor. Wir können auch
Stabilisatorgeneratoren betrachten, in denen nur X- und Identitäts-Pauli-Matrizen auftreten. Wir können uns Stabilisatorgeneratoren dieser Art als vollständig analog
zu Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren vorstellen, mit dem Unterschied, dass sie im Wesentlichen Paritätsprüfungen in der Plus-Minus-Basis beschreiben, statt in der
Standardbasis. Zum Beispiel können wir beim 7-4-3-Hamming-Code über die
restlichen drei Stabilisatorgeneratoren des 7-qubit Steane-Codes nachdenken, die exakt demselben Muster folgen wie die Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren für diesen
Code – aber diesmal ersetzen wir die Eins durch X statt durch Z. Und was wir allein aus diesen drei Stabilisatorgeneratoren erhalten,
ist ein Code, der die 16 Zustände enthält, die hier gezeigt werden. Diese erhalten wir, indem wir Hadamard gates auf die Standardbasis-
Zustände anwenden, die den Zeichenketten im 7-4-3-Hamming-Code entsprechen. Und natürlich umfasst unser Coderaum auch
Linearkombinationen dieser Zustände. Erwartungsgemäß werden Stabilisatorgeneratoren dieser Form X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren genannt.
Diesmal sind also weder Y noch Z erlaubt. Jetzt können wir CSS-Codes auf
einfache Weise definieren: CSS-Codes sind Stabilisatorcodes, die sich ausschließlich mit Z-
Stabilisatorgeneratoren und X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren ausdrücken lassen – also keine Y-Matrizen und keine X- und Z-Matrizen im selben Stabilisatorgenerator.
Und damit das klar ist: Wir sollten bedenken, dass es Freiheit bei der Wahl der Stabilisatorgeneratoren für Stabilisator-
codes gibt. Diese Definition besagt, dass ein CSS-Code einer ist, bei dem es möglich ist, ausschließlich Z- und X-
Stabilisatorgeneratoren zu wählen. Im Allgemeinen könnte man aber auch andere Stabilisatorgeneratoren wählen, die keine Z- oder X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren sind, wenn man das
möchte. Hier ist das wohl einfachste nicht-triviale Beispiel eines CSS-Codes, den wir haben können, bei dem es sowohl einen Z-Stabilisator
generator als auch einen X-Stabilisatorgenerator gibt. Das zu überprüfen erfordert kaum mehr als einen flüchtigen Blick, da wir bereits aus der
vorherigen Lektion wissen, dass dies ein gültiger Stabilisatorcode ist. Der Coderaum ist eindimensional – es ist der von einem
Φ-Plus Bell-Zustand aufgespannte Raum. Wir können beobachten, dass unsere zwei Stabilisatorgeneratoren auf diesem Vektor trivial wirken, indem wir
die beiden auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Darstellungen eines ebit betrachten, zusammen mit der Interpretation der Stabilisatorgeneratoren als Paritätsprüfungen in der 0-1-
und Plus-Minus-Basis. Der 7-qubit Steane-Code ist ein weiteres Beispiel für einen CSS-Code, denn bei dieser
Wahl der Generatoren haben wir nur Z- und X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren. Wir wissen bereits, dass dies ein gültiger
Stabilisatorcode ist. Der N9-qubit Shore-Code ist ein weiteres Beispiel. Diesmal haben wir sechs Z-
Stabilisatorgeneratoren und nur zwei X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren. Das ist in Ordnung – es muss kein Gleichgewicht oder
keine Symmetrie zwischen den beiden Typen geben. Entscheidend ist jedoch, dass wir tatsächlich einen gültigen Stabilisatorcode haben. Das bedeutet,
dass jeder der Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren mit jedem der X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren kommutieren muss. Man kann also nicht einfach
die zwei Typen von Generatoren unabhängig voneinander wählen. Darauf werde ich später in der Lektion noch etwas näher eingehen. Als nächstes besprechen wir die Fehler-
erkennung und -korrektur für CSS-Codes. Wir werden feststellen, dass die Eigenschaft, die wir beim 9-qubit Shore-
Code beobachtet haben – nämlich dass wir X-Fehler und Z-Fehler unabhängig voneinander erkennen und korrigieren können – allgemein für CSS-Codes gilt.
Um das weiter zu erklären, betrachten wir einen CSS-Code wie den 7-qubit Steane-Code – es könnte aber auch ein anderer CSS-Code sein,
wenn du willst. Die Grundidee ist, dass die Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren X-Fehler erkennen,
aber gegenüber Z-Fehlern vollständig blind sind – denn Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren kommutieren immer mit Z-
Fehlern. Außerdem kommutieren die Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren auch mit den Z gates, die wir als
Korrekturen für Z-Fehler anwenden könnten. Ebenso erkennen die X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren Z-Fehler, sind aber
gegenüber X-Fehlern und Korrekturen vollständig blind. Wir können uns also im Wesentlichen die Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren als Darstellung eines
klassischen linearen Codes vorstellen, der vor Bit-Flips – also X-Fehlern – schützt, während die X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren
einen klassischen linearen Code in der Plus-Minus-Basis darstellen, der vollständig unabhängig gegen Flips
zwischen Plus- und Minus-Zuständen schützt – also gegen Phasenflip-Fehler oder Z-Fehler. Es ist nun also recht offensichtlich, was hier passiert.
weiter mit dem Steane-Code: Es ist einfach ein 7-4-3-Hamming-Code für Bit-Flip-Fehler und ein 7-4-3-Hamming-Code für Phasen-Flip-
Fehler. Auch hier ist es erforderlich, dass die Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren und X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren kommutieren –
es wäre kein gültiger Stabilisatorcode, wenn sie das nicht täten. Man könnte sagen, es ist ein glücklicher Zufall, dass der 7-4-3-Hamming-Code
so funktioniert, aber es gibt viele andere Möglichkeiten für Paare klassischer linearer Codes, die uns einen gültigen Stabilisatorcode liefern,
wenn sie auf diese Weise kombiniert werden. Kommen wir nun wieder zu CSS-Codes im Allgemeinen: Angenommen, die Z-Stabilisator-
generatoren erlauben die Korrektur von bis zu, sagen wir, J X-Fehlern, und die X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren erlauben die Korrektur von
bis zu K Z-Fehlern. Im Fall des Steane-Codes sind J und K beide eins, weil
der 7-4-3-Hamming-Code einen Bit-Flip korrigieren kann. Im Allgemeinen können diese Zahlen J und K jedoch unterschiedlich sein.
Durch die Diskretisierung von Fehlern folgt dann, dass der CSS-Code jeden Fehler auf einer Anzahl von qubits korrigieren kann, bis zu
dem Minimum von J und K. Das liegt daran, dass ein beliebiger Fehler auf einigen qubits, wenn wir das Syndrom messen,
probabilistisch in eine Kombination aus X-Fehlern, Z-Fehlern oder beidem kollabiert und dann
die X-Fehler und Z-Fehler unabhängig voneinander erkannt und korrigiert werden können. Solange wir also zwei
klassische lineare Codes haben, die in dem Sinne kompatibel sind, dass sie uns X- und Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren liefern, die kommutieren,
erbt der CSS-Code, den wir durch ihre Kombination erhalten, im Wesentlichen die Fehlerkorrektur-Eigenschaften der beiden Codes in dem Sinne, den ich gerade
beschrieben habe. Beachte jedoch, dass es einen Preis zu zahlen gibt: Wir können nicht so viele qubits kodieren, wie wir Bits kodieren könnten
mit den beiden klassischen Codes, weil die Gesamtzahl der Stabilisatorgeneratoren für den CSS-Code die Summe der
Paritätsprüfungen der beiden klassischen Codes ist, und jeder Stabilisatorgenerator halbiert die Dimension des Coderaums.
Der 7-4-3-Hamming-Code beispielsweise erlaubt die Kodierung von vier klassischen Bits, weil wir nur
drei Paritätsprüfungen für diesen Code haben, während der 7-qubit-Steane-Code nur ein qubit kodiert, weil er sechs
Stabilisatorgeneratoren hat. Das Letzte, was ich über CSS-Codes im Allgemeinen in dieser Lektion erklären werde, betrifft Coderäume von CSS-Codes
und wie sie aussehen. Das gibt uns auch die Gelegenheit, die Beziehung, die zwischen
zwei klassischen linearen Codes bestehen muss, damit sie in dem Sinne kompatibel sind, dass wir sie zu einem CSS-
Code kombinieren können, etwas genauer zu untersuchen. Betrachte einen beliebigen CSS-Code auf N qubits und sei Z1 bis Zs der N-Bit-
Paritätsprüf-String, der den Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren entspricht. Das bedeutet, dass der klassische
lineare Code, der durch die Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren beschrieben wird – den wir CZ nennen, um uns daran zu erinnern, dass dies
der Code ist, der den Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren entspricht – die Form hat, die hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Mit anderen Worten enthält der Code jeden
String U, dessen binäres Skalarprodukt mit jedem der Paritätsprüf-Strings null ist. Wenn wir wollten, könnten wir auch
einen anderen Code betrachten, der von denselben Strings abgeleitet ist – den wir DZ nennen –, und die Idee ist, dass wir
diese Strings Z1 bis Zs nicht als Paritätsprüf-Strings, sondern als Generatoren betrachten.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist noch nicht klar, warum wir diesen Code betrachten wollen, aber wir können es tun, und es wird sich als relevant für diese
Diskussion herausstellen. Dieser Code heißt der Dualcode von CZ und wird häufig als CZ-Perp bezeichnet, also CZ mit dem Senkrechtzeichen
als Hochzeichen. Wir werden ihn aber DZ nennen, was leicht zu merken ist, weil D die Abkürzung für
Dual ist. Etwas Ähnliches können wir auch mit den X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren machen: CX ist der klassische lineare Code,
dessen Paritätsprüf-Strings den X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren entsprechen, und DX ist der Dualcode dieses Codes. Nebenbei bemerkt
können wir jetzt die Bedingungen beschreiben, die erfüllt sein müssen, damit CZ und CX in dem Sinne kompatibel sind, dass wir
sie als CSS-Code kombinieren können – ausgedrückt in diesen Codes selbst. Konkret muss gelten, dass
DZ in CX enthalten ist, oder gleichwertig, dass DX in CZ enthalten ist. Und jetzt ist es
möglich, den Coderaum des CSS-Codes, der aus diesen beiden Codes abgeleitet wird, zu beschreiben. Eine Möglichkeit, ihn zu beschreiben, ist, dass er
der Raum ist, der von allen Vektoren aufgespannt wird, die die Form haben, die auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Mit anderen Worten sehen sie wie gleichmäßige
Überlagerungen über die Strings im Dualcode DX des Codes, der den X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren entspricht, verschoben
durch bzw. XOR-verknüpft mit Strings im Code CZ, der den Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren entspricht, aus. Wir werden gleich sehen, wie das
im konkreten Fall des Steane-Codes aussieht. Das ergibt Sinn, weil Zustände im Coderaum
+1-Eigenvektoren aller Stabilisatorgeneratoren sein müssen, und insbesondere ist die Multiplikation mit einem der X-
Stabilisatorgeneratoren äquivalent zur XOR-Verknüpfung mit dem entsprechenden X-String. Deshalb erscheinen diese gleichmäßigen Überlagerungen
über DX, verschoben durch verschiedene Strings, auf diese Weise. Verschiedene Wahlmöglichkeiten für die Verschiebung,
dargestellt durch den String Y in diesem Ausdruck, können uns übrigens denselben Vektor liefern – diese Zustände sind also nicht alle verschieden, aber zusammen spannen sie den
gesamten Coderaum auf. Es gibt hier eine Symmetrie zwischen den X- und Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren und
den Codes, denen sie entsprechen. Daher können wir diese Symmetrie nutzen, um Vektoren im Coderaum auf analoge Weise zu beschreiben, indem wir X und Z vertauschen –
wir müssen aber auch die Standardbasen gegen die Plus-Minus-Basen tauschen, weshalb die Hadamard-Operationen in diesem
Ausdruck erscheinen. Kommen wir nun zum versprochenen Beispiel: beim Steane-Code erhalten wir diese beiden möglichen
Kodierungen der Null- und Eins-Standardbasiszustände. Konkret können wir den Nullzustand als gleichmäßige
Überlagerung über die acht Strings im Dualcode des 7-4-3-Hamming-Codes kodieren, was sich als die Hälfte der Strings im 7-4-3-Hamming-Code herausstellt, und wir
können den Einszustand auf ähnliche Weise kodieren, außer dass alle Strings in diesem Fall mit dem Alles-Eins-String XOR-verknüpft werden,
weil dieser String zufällig im 7-4-3-Hamming-Code, aber nicht in seinem Dualcode liegt. Ein letzter Kommentar hier ist, dass es uns oft
gar nicht so sehr interessiert, wie Vektoren in unseren Coderäumen aussehen, weil wir das im Allgemeinen nicht wissen müssen, um die
Codes zu verwenden. Falls diese Erklärung nicht klar war, ist das wirklich kein Grund zur Sorge. Es ist aber sicherlich
naheliegend zu fragen, wie Vektoren in den Coderäumen von CSS-Codes aussehen, und diese Beschreibung liefert eine Antwort auf diese
Frage. Als nächstes werden wir einen spezifischen CSS-Code besprechen, der als Torus-Code bekannt ist – ein Beispiel für etwas, das als
topologischer Quanten-Fehlerkorrekturcode bezeichnet wird. Dieser Code wurde von Alexei Kitaev entdeckt,
und zwar 1997. Tatsächlich ist der Torus-Code kein einzelner Code, sondern eine Familie von Codes – einer für jede positive ganze Zahl von
mindestens zwei. Diese Codes besitzen einige Schlüsseleigenschaften. Die erste Schlüsseleigenschaft ist,
dass alle Stabilisatorgeneratoren niedriges Gewicht als Pauli-Operationen haben. Konkret werden sie alle
Gewicht vier haben. Das ist gut, weil es bedeutet, dass jede der Stabilisatorgenerator-Messungen nicht
zu viele qubits einbeziehen muss. Manchmal spricht man von Quanten-LDPC-Codes oder Quanten-Low-Density-Parity-
Check-Codes – das ist es, was mit diesem Begriff gemeint ist, wobei „low" in diesem Fall vier bedeutet. Der Torus-Code ist also ein Beispiel für einen
Quanten-LDPC-Code. Der Torus-Code hat auch das, was man geometrische Lokalität nennt, was bedeutet, dass nicht
nicht nur haben die Stabilisatorgeneratoren ein geringes Gewicht, sondern es ist auch möglich, die qubits räumlich so anzuordnen, dass
jede der Stabilisatorgenerator-Messungen nur qubits umfasst, die nah beieinander liegen, was diese Messungen leichter implementierbar macht in
der Praxis, und schließlich haben diese Codes eine große Distanz, sodass sie eine relativ hohe Rate von
Fehlern tolerieren können. So funktionieren diese Codes: Sei zunächst L eine positive
ganze Zahl, die mindestens zwei ist, und betrachte ein L×L-Gitter mit sogenannten periodischen
Randbedingungen. Hier zum Beispiel ist ein L×L-Gitter für L = 8, und man beachte, dass die Linien
rechts und unten gestrichelte Linien sind. Die Idee dabei ist, dass wir die gestrichelte Linie rechts als dieselbe Linie betrachten wollen wie
die Linie links, und ebenso ist die gestrichelte Linie unten dieselbe Linie wie die
oben. Wenn wir diese Art von Konfiguration also tatsächlich physisch realisieren wollten, bräuchten wir drei
Dimensionen. Insbesondere könnten wir einen Zylinder bilden, indem wir zunächst die linke und rechte Seite zusammenführen und dann den
Zylinder so biegen, dass die Kreise an den Enden, die früher die obere und untere Kante des Gitters waren, sich treffen – oder du
kannst zuerst oben und unten zusammenführen und dann die Seiten. Es funktioniert in beide Richtungen, und es spielt keine Rolle, wie du es machst – für die Zwecke dieser
Erläuterung erhalten wir einen Torus, oder mit anderen Worten einen Donut, obwohl die Vorstellung eines Fahrradschlauchs
vielleicht ein besseres Bild ist, denn das ist kein Volumen – das Gitter ist tatsächlich nur die Oberfläche eines
Torus geworden, und daher kommt der Name Torus-Code. Wie du dich auf einem
solchen Torus bewegen kannst – vorausgesetzt, du kannst dich zwischen benachbarten Punkten des Gitters bewegen – wird Leuten vertraut sein, die alte Videospiele gespielt haben,
bei denen du, wenn du den oberen Bildschirmrand verlässt, unten wieder auftauchst, und entsprechend für den linken und rechten Rand des
Bildschirms. Und größtenteils ist das die Art, wie ich dieses Gitter beschreiben werde, anstatt explizit über einen
Torus im dreidimensionalen Raum zu sprechen. Als nächstes stellen wir uns vor, dass qubits auf den
Kanten des Gitters platziert werden, wie hier auf dem Bildschirm dargestellt, wobei qubits durch ausgefüllte blaue
Kreise angezeigt werden. Man beachte übrigens, dass die qubits auf den gestrichelten Linien nicht ausgefüllt sind, weil wir diese qubits bereits dargestellt haben
durch die entlang der oberen oder linken Seite – mit dem Hinweis, dass die Linien oben und links genau dieselben Linien sind wie die
durch die gestrichelten Linien unten und rechts angezeigten. Wenn wir also alle diese qubits zählen, erhalten wir 2 × L² qubits, und eine
Möglichkeit, das zu sehen, ist zu beobachten, dass wir L² qubits auf horizontalen Kanten und L² qubits auf vertikalen
Kanten erhalten. Das ist also die Anordnung unserer qubits. Um den Torus-Code selbst zu beschreiben, müssen wir nur die Stabilisator-
generatoren beschreiben, und davon gibt es zwei Typen. Zunächst haben wir Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren,
die Flächen oder Kacheln in der Abbildung entsprechen, und zweitens haben wir X-Stabilisator-
generatoren, die Eckpunkten in der Abbildung entsprechen. Hier ist zum Beispiel ein
Stabilisatorgenerator: Wir tensorieren eine Pauli-Z-Operation für jeden der qubits, die diese Kachel berühren, zusammen mit Identitätsmatrizen
auf allen anderen qubits, was uns eine Pauli-Operation vom Gewicht 4 gibt. Und hier ist ein Beispiel für einen X-
Stabilisatorgenerator, bei dem Pauli-X-Matrizen auf die vier qubits wirken, die zu diesem Eckpunkt inzident sind, zusammen mit
Identitätsmatrizen auf allen anderen qubits. Es ist also wiederum eine Pauli-Operation vom Gewicht 4. Wichtig ist, dass für beide
Typen von Stabilisatorgeneratoren auch die einbezogen werden, die an den periodischen Randbedingungen umherlaufen. Hier ist ein Beispiel für einen X-Stabilisatorgenerator,
der das tut. Um nun einen gültigen Stabilisator-Code zu erhalten, müssen die Stabilisator-
generatoren kommutieren. Die Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren kommutieren alle miteinander, weil Z mit sich selbst kommutiert und die Identität
mit allem kommutiert, und entsprechend für die X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren. Es ist auch klar, dass ein Z-Stabilisatorgenerator und ein X-
Stabilisatorgenerator kommutieren, wenn sie nicht-trivial auf disjunkten Mengen von qubits wirken, wie bei den beiden gezeigten Generatoren.
Die verbleibende Möglichkeit ist, dass ein Z-Stabilisatorgenerator und ein X-Stabilisatorgenerator überlappen, und
wann immer das passiert, überlappen sie sich immer auf zwei qubits, sodass die Stabilisatorgeneratoren kommutieren, weil ZX und
XZ kommutieren. Das ist jetzt keine minimale Menge von Stabilisatorgeneratoren. Insbesondere, wenn wir alle
Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren zusammenmultiplizieren, erhalten wir die Identität, weil jeder qubit zweimal mit Z multipliziert wird –
einmal für jede Kachel, die den qubit berührt. Das bedeutet, dass das Multiplizieren aller Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren
außer einem uns den letzten gibt – sie sind also nicht unabhängig. Aber wenn wir einen davon entfernen, erhalten wir
eine unabhängige Menge, und dasselbe gilt für die X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren. Wir können also je einen entfernen,
und es spielt keine Rolle, welche wir entfernen. Das ergibt L² minus eins Stabilisatorgeneratoren von jedem Typ. Um
das klarzustellen – und das ist etwas, das ich in der vorherigen Lektion angedeutet habe – interessieren wir uns tatsächlich für alle diese Stabilisatorgeneratoren, und im streng
operativen Sinne werden wir nicht einen von jedem Typ zum Ignorieren auswählen. Aber für die Analyse des Codes können wir uns
vorstellen, dass ein Stabilisatorgenerator von jedem Typ entfernt wurde, sodass wir eine minimale Erzeugendenmenge erhalten – mit dem Hinweis,
dass wir die Ergebnisse dieser entfernten Generatoren – wenn wir sie als Observablen betrachten – immer aus den Ergebnissen aller anderen Stabilisator-
generatorobservablen desselben Typs ableiten könnten. Die Anzahl der qubits, die dieser Code kodiert, ist gleich der Gesamtanzahl der
qubits, also 2 × L², minus der Gesamtanzahl der Stabilisatorgeneratoren in einer minimalen Erzeugendenmenge, also 2 × L² −
2, und das bedeutet, wir können 2 qubits kodieren. Ich habe übrigens nicht argumentiert, dass der Codespace nicht-trivial ist, aber er ist es tatsächlich,
und ich überlasse es dir, dich selbst davon zu überzeugen, dass es keine Möglichkeit gibt, Stabilisatorgeneratoren so zusammenzumultiplizieren, dass wir
−1 mal die Identität erhalten. Das ist also der Torus-Code selbst, und an diesem Punkt ist es vielleicht gar nicht
klar, warum dieser Code gut für die Quantenfehlerkorrektur sein sollte. Es bleibt uns, ihn zu analysieren, und was wir herausfinden werden, ist, dass er tatsächlich ein
ziemlich erstaunlicher Quantenfehlerkorrektur-Code ist. Um zu verstehen, wie der Torus-Code als Quantenfehlerkorrektur-
Code funktioniert, beginnen wir damit, verschiedene Fehler und die Syndrome zu betrachten, die sie erzeugen. Das erste, was zu beachten ist, ist, dass
der Torus-Code ein CSS-Code ist, weil alle unsere Stabilisatorgeneratoren entweder Z- oder X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren sind.
Und das bedeutet, dass X-Fehler und Z-Fehler unabhängig voneinander erkannt und möglicherweise korrigiert werden können.
Tatsächlich gibt es eine einfache Symmetrie zwischen den Z- und X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren, die es uns erlaubt, X-
Fehler und Z-Fehler im Wesentlichen auf dieselbe Weise zu analysieren. Ich werde mich also auf X-Fehler konzentrieren, die möglicherweise von Z-
Stabilisatorgeneratoren erkannt werden, und du kannst alles auf Z-Fehler übertragen, die möglicherweise von den X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren erkannt werden, indem du genau dieselben
Ideen verwendest. Hier ist eine Abbildung, die unsere 2 × L² qubits auf den Kanten eines L×
L-Gitters mit periodischen Randbedingungen zeigt, und wir können uns vorstellen, dass dies auf der Oberfläche eines
Torus angeordnet ist. Im Moment sind alle qubits blau, was anzeigt, dass dies qubits sind, die nicht von
Fehler, also stell dir vor, dass der Zustand dieser qubits an diesem Punkt im Code-Raum für diesen
Code liegt. Wie bereits erwähnt, liegt unser Fokus auf X-Fehlern, und gleich werden wir magentafarbene Kreise verwenden, um qubits anzuzeigen, die
von X-Fehlern betroffen wurden. X-Fehler werden durch Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren erkannt, die Kacheln in der Abbildung entsprechen
also können wir weiße Kacheln verwenden, um Plus-Eins-Messergebnisse anzuzeigen, oder mit anderen Worten
Einträge im Syndrom, die diesem Generator entsprechen, während graue Kacheln Minus-Eins-Mess-
ergebnisse anzeigen. Du kannst dir ein Plus-Eins-Ergebnis, oder mit anderen Worten eine weiße Kachel, so vorstellen, dass der entsprechende
Stabilisatorgenerator zufrieden ist – alles scheint für diesen Generator in Ordnung zu sein. Ein Minus-Eins-Ergebnis oder eine graue Kachel
zeigt an, dass der entsprechende Stabilisatorgenerator unzufrieden ist, weil offensichtlich ein Fehler aufgetreten sein muss, um dieses
Ergebnis zu verursachen. Im Moment sind also alle unsere Stabilisatorgeneratoren zufrieden, weil keine Fehler aufgetreten sind. Wenn wir nun über
einen Z-Stabilisatorgenerator nachdenken, misst er lediglich die Parität der 4 qubits, die die Kachel berühren,
bezüglich der Standardbasis. Ein Plus-Eins-Ergebnis zeigt also nicht an, dass keine X-Fehler auf diesen vier
qubits aufgetreten sind, sondern es zeigt an, dass eine gerade Anzahl von X-Fehlern aufgetreten ist, während ein Minus-Eins-Ergebnis anzeigt,
dass eine ungerade Anzahl von X-Fehlern aufgetreten ist. Führen wir nun also einen X-Fehler ein und schauen, was
passiert. Die zwei Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren, die den Kacheln entsprechen, die dieses qubit berühren, sind jetzt unzufrieden, weil dieser
X-Fehler mit beiden Generatoren anti-kommutiert, oder gleichwertig ausgedrückt in Bezug auf die Standardbasis befinden wir uns jetzt in
einem Zustand, in dem beide dieser Mengen von vier qubits, die den zwei Kacheln entsprechen, ungerade Parität haben. Das ist also der Effekt eines einzelnen
X-Fehlers. Wenn wir dieses Syndrom messen würden und wüssten oder annähmen, dass genau ein X-Fehler aufgetreten ist, könnten wir
leicht ableiten, welches qubit umgekippt wurde, und könnten es einfach mit einem X-gate zurückklappen. Schauen wir jetzt, was passiert,
wenn wir weitere X-Fehler einführen, und schauen wir insbesondere, was passiert, wenn ein zweiter X-Fehler auf einem anderen
qubit auftritt, das eine der grauen Kacheln berührt – sagen wir die graue Kachel oben, etwa
so. Diese Kachel ist jetzt zufrieden, weil zwei X-Fehler auf den qubits aufgetreten sind, die diese Kachel berühren, und zwei ist gerade, also
kommutieren diese zwei X-Fehler zusammen mit dem Stabilisatorgenerator für diese Kachel. Eine andere Möglichkeit das zu sagen ist, dass
dieser zweite X-Fehler alle Standardbasiszustände dieser vier qubits von ungerader Parität zurück zu gerader
Parität verschoben hat. Die Kachel links von diesem neuen X-Fehler hingegen ist jetzt unzufrieden.
Wir können diesen Prozess des Hinzufügens neuer X-Fehler fortsetzen, und solange wir eine Kette benachbarter X-Fehler bilden, wobei benachbart bedeutet, dass die qubits dieselbe Kachel berühren,
werden wir dieses Minus-Eins-Messergebnis effektiv verschieben, und was wir feststellen ist, dass wir immer
Minus-Eins-Syndrom-Messergebnisse an den Endpunkten von Ketten benachbarter Fehler haben. Wir können also immer Ketten von
benachbarten X-Fehlern erkennen, solange sie Endpunkte haben. Es könnte übrigens mehrere Ketten geben, aber wir kommen
später auf diese Möglichkeit zurück. Es ist jedoch möglich, dass wir eine Kette benachbarter X-Fehler haben,
die keine Endpunkte hat, das heißt, unsere Fehlerkette könnte eine geschlossene Schleife bilden. Fügen wir also weitere Fehler hinzu,
sodass sie eine geschlossene Schleife bilden, etwa so. Jetzt haben wir eine gerade Anzahl von X-
Fehlern auf jeder Kachel, also ist jeder Stabilisatorgenerator jetzt zufrieden, und was wir festgestellt haben, ist, dass geschlossene
Schleifen benachbarter X-Fehler von diesem Code nicht erkannt werden, weil wir in einem solchen
Fall das vollständige Plus-Eins-Syndrom erhalten. Das mag zunächst etwas enttäuschend erscheinen. Tatsächlich brauchen wir nur vier benachbarte X-Fehler, um eine geschlossene Schleife zu bilden,
und wir hoffen auf etwas Besseres als einen Code der Distanz 4. Einige geschlossene Schleifen von
benachbarten X-Fehlern befinden sich jedoch selbst im Stabilisator. Denk daran, dass wir für jeden Knoten im
Gitter einen X-Stabilisatorgenerator haben, und wenn wir benachbarte X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren miteinander multiplizieren, können wir geschlossene Schleifen von X-
Operationen bilden, wie wir sie hier haben, für die geschlossene Schleife, die wir vor wenigen Momenten konstruiert haben. Einige geschlossene Schleifen von X-Fehlern
wie die hier gezeigte sind also eigentlich gar keine Fehler, weil sie im Stabilisator sind, sodass sie dem Code-Raum überhaupt nichts antun. Es gibt jedoch
einige geschlossene Schleifen von X-Fehlern, die nicht im Stabilisator sind, und daher repräsentieren sie nicht-triviale Fehler, die vom
Code unerkannt bleiben. Und es gibt eine ziemlich einfache Möglichkeit, die verschiedenen Typen von
Schleifen zu charakterisieren. Schleifen, die jede Linie im Gitter kreuzen, also jede vertikale Linie von oben nach unten und jede horizontale Linie
von links nach rechts eine gerade Anzahl von Malen, sind immer Produkte von X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren. Das schließt das Beispiel
auf dem Bildschirm ein sowie Schleifen, die möglicherweise viel komplizierter sind, einschließlich der Möglichkeit, dass sie die periodischen Grenzen kreuzen, aber
durch Multiplikation dieser geschlossenen Schleifen von X-Fehlern mit X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren können sie dennoch effektiv auf
nichts zusammengezogen werden. Und es ist sicherlich wahr, dass wir Schleifen dieser Art nur erhalten können, indem wir X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren miteinander multiplizieren, denn jeder X-Stabilisator-
generator setzt eine gerade Anzahl von X-Operationen auf jede horizontale Linie und auf jede vertikale
Linie. Der andere Typ von geschlossener Schleife, den wir haben können, ist einer, der mindestens eine Linie eine ungerade Anzahl von Malen kreuzt, wie etwa
die hier gezeigte, die jede horizontale Linie genau einmal kreuzt. Und hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel, das
jede vertikale Linie genau einmal kreuzt. Das sind also Beispiele nicht-trivialer Fehler, die vom Code unerkannt bleiben. Aber der Schlüssel
liegt darin, dass die einzige Möglichkeit, eine solche geschlossene Schleife zu bilden, darin besteht, um den Torus herum zu gehen – entweder um das Loch in der
Mitte des Torus oder durch das Loch hindurch, oder es könnte beides sein. Das ist eine topologische Eigenschaft,
die den Torus betrifft. Es geht im Wesentlichen um die Löcher, und deshalb nennt man das einen topologischen Quanten-Fehlerkorrektur-
Code. In Bezug auf diese Visualisierung eines zweidimensionalen Gitters mit periodischen Grenzen muss eine Kette in dieser Kategorie
um eine oder beide der periodischen Grenzen herumführen, auf eine Weise, die es unmöglich macht, diese Schleife auf einen
Punkt zusammenzuziehen, indem man sie mit X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren multipliziert. Eine solche Kette könnte
komplizierter sein als die hier dargestellte, aber das ist die kürzeste, die eine solche Schleife sein kann, weil sie irgendwie um
eine oder beide der periodischen Grenzen herumführen muss. Und was das impliziert, ist, dass das minimale Gewicht eines nicht-trivialen
nicht erkennbaren Fehlers L ist. Jede geschlossene Schleife mit weniger Fehlern als das muss in die erste Kategorie fallen und befindet sich daher
im Stabilisator, und Fehlerketten, die keine geschlossenen Schleifen bilden, werden vom Code erkannt. Das war's – deshalb funktioniert dieser Code.
Und was wir erhalten, ist ein [[2L², 2, L]]-Stabilisatorcode. Wir verwenden 2L²
qubits, um 2 qubits zu kodieren, und der Code hat Distanz L. Als Nächstes werde ich noch kurz etwas über
die Fehlerkorrektur mit dem Torus-Code sagen, ohne allzu sehr ins Detail zu gehen. Wenn wir das Syndrom messen und
etwas anderes als das vollständige Plus-Eins-Syndrom sehen – wobei ich hier nur von den Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren spreche –
zeigen uns die Minus-Eins-Ergebnisse die Endpunkte einer oder mehrerer Ketten benachbarter X-Fehler an, und wir können versuchen, diese
Fehler zu korrigieren, indem wir die Minus-Eins-Ergebnisse paarweise zusammenfassen und eine Kette von X-Korrekturen zwischen ihnen bilden. Und wie
wir tun das, macht es Sinn, kürzeste Pfade für unsere Korrekturen zu wählen – wenn wir zum Beispiel ein
Syndrom wie das hier gezeigte messen, könnten wir diesen Pfad zwischen den unglücklichen Kacheln wählen und X
Gates als Korrekturen entlang dieses Pfades anwenden. Natürlich könnte die tatsächliche Fehlerkette, die das Syndrom verursacht, auch
anders gewesen sein, wie die hier gezeigte – aber das ist in Ordnung, solange die Fehler und die Korrekturen zusammen
in den Stabilisator fallen. Es könnte auch sein, dass unsere Korrekturen eine Schleife um den
Torus schließen, was schlecht wäre, da wir dadurch einen logischen Fehler verursacht haben. Diese Strategie, entlang
kürzester Pfade zu korrigieren, korrigiert Fehler mit niedrigem Gewicht, funktioniert aber möglicherweise nicht bei Fehlern mit höherem Gewicht. Natürlich können wir
von keinem Quantenfehlerkorrekturcode mehr erwarten. Wahrscheinlicher – je nach Rauschmodell – ist, dass wir
eine Reihe von Minus-Einsen im Syndrom beobachten, und in diesem Fall können wir effiziente klassische Algorithmen nutzen,
um sie paarweise zuzuordnen und einen Fehler mit niedrigstem Gewicht zu finden, der das Syndrom darstellt – wie ich in der vorherigen
Lektion erwähnt habe. Das korrigiert nicht immer die wahrscheinlichste Erklärung für das Syndrom, funktioniert aber im Allgemeinen recht gut
und korrigiert stets erfolgreich Fehler, deren Gewicht strikt kleiner als die halbe Distanz L ist. Ich sollte auch
erwähnen, dass es andere Strategien gibt, die besser für verschiedene Fehlermodelle geeignet sind. Es sind über 25 Jahre vergangen, seit der
Tor-Code entdeckt wurde, und in dieser Zeit wurde eine ganze Menge an Arbeit in Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes gesteckt,
darunter andere topologische Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes, die vom Toric Code inspiriert wurden, sowie Codes auf der Grundlage anderer
Ideen. Ich kann dir sicher keine umfassende Liste aller bekannten Code-Konstruktionen geben, aber ich werde die Oberfläche
ein wenig ankratzen und kurz ein paar bekannte Beispiele nennen. Zunächst stellt sich heraus, dass es nicht
wirklich entscheidend ist, dass der Toric Code periodische Randbedingungen hat – es ist nämlich möglich, nur einen Teil des Toric Codes herauszuschneiden und
ihn flach auf einer zweidimensionalen Fläche statt auf einem Torus auszulegen. Was wir dadurch erhalten, nennt sich Surface
Code. Wenn wir zum Beispiel die Kanten eines Gitters im hier gezeigten Muster schneiden – mit sogenannten rauen Kanten oben und
unten sowie glatten Kanten an den Seiten – und entsprechend Randfälle für die Stabilisatorgeneratoren einbeziehen,
erhalten wir diesmal einen Code, der genau ein qubit kodieren kann. Dennoch übernimmt der Code die wichtigsten
Eigenschaften des Toric Codes – insbesondere müssen nicht-triviale, unerkennbare Fehler für diesen Code
Fehlerketten entsprechen, die entweder von der linken Kante zur rechten Kante oder von oben nach unten verlaufen,
je nachdem, ob es sich um Ketten von X-Fehlern oder Z-Fehlern handelt. Es ist auch möglich, die
Kanten diagonal zu schneiden, um sogenannte rotierte Surface Codes zu erhalten, was dabei helfen kann,
die Codes hinsichtlich der Anzahl verwendeter qubits effizienter zu gestalten. Wenn wir zum Beispiel diesen Surface
Code nehmen und einige qubits entfernen, sodass ein diagonal ausgerichtetes Quadrat übrig bleibt, erhalten wir einen weiteren Surface
Code – sofern wir die Stabilisatorgeneratoren am Rand auf die richtige Weise festlegen. Diagramme wie diese sind
hilfreich, um klar zu machen, wie die Stabilisatorgeneratoren definiert sind: Schwarze Kacheln – einschließlich der abgerundeten an den Rändern – kennzeichnen X-Stabilisator-
generatoren, die weißen kennzeichnen Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren. Die Kacheln am Rand sind übrigens diesmal nur 2-qubit-XX-
oder ZZ-Stabilisatorgeneratoren, und diese Diagramme sieht man häufig um
45° gedreht. Eine weitere interessante Klasse von Codes, die ebenfalls in die allgemeine Kategorie topologischer Codes fallen, sind Color
Codes. Ich werde nicht genau erklären, wie sie funktionieren, aber eine Möglichkeit, sie zu verstehen, ist, dass sie geometrische Verallgemeinerungen
des 7-qubit-Steane-Codes sind. Betrachten wir also den 7-qubit-Steane-Code und nehmen an, dass wir unsere
qubits mithilfe der KCET-Nummerierungskonvention nummerieren, wie hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Wir können diese sieben
qubits dann den Knoten des hier gezeigten Graphen zuordnen, und wir stellen fest, dass die Stabilisatorgeneratoren mit den
Kacheln bzw. Flächen übereinstimmen, die durch die Kanten des Graphen gebildet werden. Für jede Kachel haben wir immer einen Z-Stabilisator-
generator und einen X-Stabilisatorgenerator, die nicht-trivial auf genau jenen qubits wirken, die an den Ecken dieser
Kachel liegen. Das ist schön, denn genau wie beim Toric Code haben wir für diesen Code geometrische Lokalität – wir müssen also keine
qubits über große Distanzen bewegen, um Stabilisatorgeneratoren zu messen. Und die Tatsache, dass Z- und X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren immer nicht-trivial auf
exakt denselben qubit-Mengen wirken, ist aus Gründen, die mit fehlertoleranter Quantenberechnung zusammenhängen, ebenfalls von Vorteil – dazu
werde ich in der nächsten Lektion mehr sagen. Color Codes sind Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes, die dieses
grundlegende Muster verallgemeinern, wobei wir im Wesentlichen dasselbe tun, aber mit anderen Graphen. Hier ist zum Beispiel ein Graph mit
19 Knoten, der funktioniert. Dieser ergibt einen Code, der 1 qubit in 19 kodiert, und er hat zufällig
Distanz fünf. Diese heißen übrigens Color Codes, weil eine der erforderlichen Bedingungen an den Graphen ist, dass die Flächen dreifärbbar sind – das heißt,
wir können die Flächen mit drei Farben einfärben, ohne dass zwei benachbarte Flächen dieselbe Farbe haben. Die
Farben sind für den Code selbst eigentlich nicht relevant – wir haben einfach X- und Z-Stabilisatorgeneratoren für jede Fläche unabhängig von ihrer Farbe –, aber die Farben
erweisen sich als wichtig für die Analyse, wie er funktioniert. Das waren also zwei sehr bekannte
Code-Familien, aber es gibt noch viele andere bekannte Konstruktionen, darunter solche, die auf ähnlichen Ideen wie diese Code-Familien basieren, sowie
völlig andere. Ein konkretes Beispiel für einen Quantenfehlerkorrekturcode, der kürzlich
von einigen meiner Kollegen bei IBM entdeckt wurde, ist bekannt als der Gross-Code, der so benannt ist, weil ein Gross ein Dutzend
Dutzend oder 144 ist. Konkret kodiert dieser Code 12 qubits in 144 qubits, und er hat
Distanz 12. Ich werde nicht im Detail erklären, wie dieser Code funktioniert – er ähnelt dem Toric Code, außer dass jeder der
Stabilisatorgeneratoren jetzt zwei zusätzliche qubits einbezieht, die ein bisschen weiter entfernt sind. Er hat keine planare Einbettung
wie ein Surface Code, hat aber eine sogenannte Banner-Einbettung, was bedeutet, dass zwei Schichten von qubits benötigt werden statt
einer. Er gehört zu einer Code-Familie namens bivariate bicycle codes, und was besonders bemerkenswert an ihnen ist,
ist, dass sie viel effizienter sind als der Toric Code oder ein Surface Code – in dem Sinne, dass wesentlich mehr qubits kodiert werden können, während sie gleichzeitig
ungefähr die gleiche Fehlerrate tolerieren. Für den Gross-Code werden zusätzlich 144 qubits für die Syndrom-
messung benötigt, sodass die Gesamtzahl der erforderlichen qubits 288 beträgt, was ihn zu einem sehr vielversprechenden Kandidaten für die heutige
Technologie macht. Damit schließt diese Lektion, die sich mit Konstruktionen von Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes befasst hat, einschließlich CSS-Codes, des Toric Codes sowie einem
Einblick in weitere Quantencode-Konstruktionen, darunter Surface Codes und Color Codes. Ich hoffe, du wirst mich zur
nächsten und letzten Lektion der Reihe über fehlertolerante Quantenberechnung begleiten, die sich der Herausforderung widmet, Berechnungen auf
kodierten Quantenzuständen mithilfe von Operationen und Rechenkomponenten durchzuführen, die selbst fehleranfällig sind.
Auf Wiedersehen bis dahin.